تمييز بين واقع مختلف يعيشه الطفل سلمان
الان وبين حاله عندما كان في مهده اذ كاد
يفارق فيه الحياه هنا يلعبون ولا يعرف
شيئا سوى الحياه ولا يعرف ايضا كيف كانت
حالته
[موسيقى]
سنه
وتبين عنده ثقوب فتحات في القلب قبل عامين
رافقنا رحله طبيه اشبه برحله المصير
بواسطه طائره الاخلاء الطبيعه للخدمات
الطبيه بوزاره الدفاع السعوديه رحله لم
تكون شاقه بقدر ما كانت تحتاج الى السرعه
الطاقه والتطبي يتابع حاله سلمان الرضيع
الذي كان يبلغ عمره انا ذاك ثلاثه اشهر
وقلبه ضعيف قد يفقده الحياه
[موسيقى]
الرحله المصيريه والحساسه كانت مدتها 56
دقيقه جوا من محافظه خميس مشيط جنوبا الى
الرياض العاصمه
[موسيقى]
طائره طبيه جهزت لسلمان الذي كان لابد من
نقله الى مستشفى تتوفر فيه الامكانيات
الطبيه الحديثه ويمتلك طاقما طبيا مختصر
مخاطبه المستشفى الرياض
بخصوص نقل حاله الطفل الى مستشفى متقدم
لاجراء عمليه له في القلب
من ذكريات الطائره سلمان لم يكن يشعر بما
يدور حوله والده كان يحلق طيله الوقت الى
بلد كبده
[موسيقى]
بالحب كبراس سويا والان يضحكان معا
وبينهما الحب والامان
هاني صبيان العربيه الرياض